do you think there's any correlation
between binge viewers being younger
versus standalone viewers and older
because we're more used to watching Love
Boat great journey on Saturdays and then
BAM wait till next week well there's
absolutely a huge difference in H the
demographic for standalone shows which
tend to be things like detective stories
sometimes legal dramas hospital drama
and so on are much older the the
demographic for detective shows the
oldest demographic there is whereas for
these kind of cereal shows you it's
always a much younger audience and older
audiences have proven time and again
they are not interested in doing binge
viewing
you